TONIGHT, AS CAPITALS TEAM
IN NAVY BLUE VERY WELL, HOW
WILL THE MONTH OF APRIL FAIR AS
BEHIND IN IT TOO LONG BUT A
BEAUTIFUL STRETCH PASS AND INTO
IN THE 2nd MINUTE OF THE A RIPP.
LEAVES IT
>> Joe: SEEING THEM SCROLL TO C
>> FUNNELING INTO WINNING 3-1
HE HAS IN HIS HANDND IN
TRANSITION,  THE SCRUM, ALONG OL
AROUND GAME, ESTABLISHING THAT
ZONE LIKE WE WERE
OFFENSE, NICE BY NICK
BACKSTROM,ABOVE
THE PENALTY KILL, RECENTLY
OPERATING  MIGHT
BE ABLE TO DO THAT, HE IS THAT
WASHINGTONTHIRD, A MINIMUM ONE
A
FOR, ONLY 10 VIPS REMAIN,
SILENT AUCTI
BEAUTIFUL PASSING PLAY BY
JOE'S, AND YOU CAN SEE UNTNTAGAE
PANTHERS HAVE BEEN MARVELOUSCAPS
ATTACK.
TYING THINGS UP, NOTTHE BID IS
VANNA CHECK, MAKES ANOTHER
SPEED TO GET BACK IN THE HOCKEY
THE GREAT MIKE MULINO PUTS STAGT
FOR WASHINGTON.
THE INSIDE EDGE OF THE
TONIGHT.>> Joe: MAGICALLY THEY
DISAPPEAR, ITHE POSTSEASON, A
QUICK SPIN THERE BY